You're getting married.
Why are you getting married?
So people think I'm straight?
Yeah!
My girlfriend's half Greek,
there's a chance our kid maybe
born a block of feta cheese.
A hundred percent.
Absolutely, but definitely
gonna have one eyebrow.
I'm going to your wedding.
You are?
Yeah I'm gonna go
to your wedding bad.
You cannot wear a baseball
jersey, you gotta buy a suit.
I really, the thing is,
I don't have any suits.
No.
What's up? Back at the bar here,
I'm still with my boy here
Yannis Pappas,
aka Freddy Feta Cheese.
What do you think is the most
childish thing people as adults?
Everything that adults do now,
is childish? Right? Yeah.
Everybody wants to
have a kid now.
Nobody can believe
I have a child.
They're like what? You're 33!
You just threw
your whole life away.
It's like, if this was
a hundred years ago,
I'd almost be dead right now.
Absolutely!
I'd have tuberculosis!
My kid would be 28.
Remember when we were kids,
you saw your daddy
was wearing a suit?
Yup.
He was 15 years old?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My dad had fought in four wars
by the time he was 24.
I mean look at you, you're 42.
Can you imagine if your dad
saw you like this?
I imagine if my grandfather
saw me, oh my god!
Doing skits.
Doing skits!
He'd be like you're getting
paid to do this?
This is a job?
Yeah.
Yeah, no.
I want you to look into that
camera and apologize to him.
I'm sorry!
You piece of shit!
Would you rather accidentally
sext your mom or sext your dad?
I'd like to sext my dad cause
it would be funny yeah.
My mom, I already
do sext her so.
I don't think I've sext my mom,
but I, I sent a dick pic.
You know I sent it to a girl,
and I accidentally
I tagged my mom,
like I, I attached my mom.
That's right, yeah,
she never responded.
It was a remote?
Was it a remote thing?
It was when I stuffed a remote
control in my sweat pants.
Yeah I don't show
my actual penis.
Yeah, I mean, I'm half Irish.
All right, next stupid question.
Would you rather be known
as the crying guy
or the lotion guy?
I'd rather be known
as the lotion guy.
Why?
Cause it sounds
like a better time.
Yeah, I cry a lot.
I am known as the lotion guy
to myself.
We all got secrets Gus.
When I was a young kid,
I wasn't the brightest kid.
I stuck my dick in a vapor rub
just to see if it burned.
That's what happens.
It does a lot.
True story, not a joke.
Yeah, I'm the crying kid.
You are?
Yeah, I cry, how many times
have I cried to you?
Fifteen, I counted them
because they were so jarring.
Would you rather go on a hot air
balloon blindfolded
or go to a ballet
with earplugs in?
Hot air ballon blindfolded.
You rather do that?
Yeah, because I'll get
the butterflies in my stomach.
Yeah.
So it's a little bit of a high.
If I go to a ballet,
I'll close my eyes
and fall asleep.
I like to go on
the hot air balloon,
ride with you
and blindfold you
and then push you
right overboard.
That's a good way to go.
I like to watch you fall, and
explode into feather crumble.
Is that what you like?
Yup, that's what I want
to do to you.
Well, I'd like to walk you up
to a hill in Poughkeepsie,
Yeah
Make you dig your own hole,
yeah,
And shoot you into it.
Yeah! Yeah.
All right so,
did you have a good time?
I had a great time.
Gus, you know
you're my best friend,
and I got you a gift.
Wow!
Yeah.
I didn't get you anything.
All right, cause you're Greek,
I wanted to get you
a bag of Feta crumble.
Wow!
Yeah, it's kinda,
it's also a wedding gift
Oh my god!
For you and your fiancee.
It's too much man!
Yeah.
Thank you.
Cool.
I love you man.
Yeah, yeah,
you smell like olive oil.
It's organic.
Dude, that stinks.
That is organic huh?
Yeah.
That comes, that came right
from a Greek's woman.
(Laughs)